bring you about what's happened up in
Nottingham police detectives there have
been given extra time to question a
murder suspect as part of their
investigations they have revealed to us
that the suspect is a former University
of Nottingham student himself
they are saying but that this is not
believed to be connected to the attack
and then they say that they have also
referred themselves to the iopc that is
the independent office of police conduct
because the van went when this man took
the van and tried to run over
pedestrians was being followed by a
marked police car for a short distance
before it collided with the two
pedestrians that police then detained
the suspect using a taser when the
vehicle was stopped they say that they
are still working alongside
counter-terror policing and keeping an
open mind on the motives behind those
attacks so police saying that they have
been granted an extra 36 hours to
question the man held on connection with
the murders of three people in that city
of Nottingham and that they have
revealed that the suspect himself is a
former University of Nottingham student
and another bit of breaking news today
the mother of Alfie Steele has been
sentenced to 17 years in prison for his
manslaughter and her partner has been
sentenced to 27 years for murdering the
nine-year-old let's take you to Coventry
Police are giving a statement there